hi my name is Jack Dorsey and I'm one of
the cofounders of Twitter and this is
Twitter support at Baby seok's my
English teacher just told me the Twitter
bird's name is Larry well our co-founder
biz is from Boston and when we decided
that the bird was going to be our logo
he naturally went to the most famous
bird for him maybe the most famous bird
in the world
Larry Bird I will say though if you
follow bird watching on Twitter no
tweets about Larry Bird and Maddie
creates us why does Twitter have a
character limit still I'm tired of
sacrificing my grammar for the good of
the tweet unhappy face so some history
on the character limit we originally
started with 140 characters so that we
could fit in one text message which is
what the whole service was based on in
the early days but we also believe that
the constraint was really useful because
it inspired a lot of creativity and this
resonated with comedians it resonated
with journalists it resonated with poets
and hip-hop artists and creatives of all
type figure out ways not to sacrifice
their grammar but to actually make it
work but we thought they might be good
to increase the limit just a little bit
and we decided to do it twice the amount
which seems enough for most people and
if that's not enough we have threads you
can link all the tweets together so we
have a 280 character limit but you can
link as many tweets as you want so it's
really limitless at my wife is Joanie
asks how can I identify a Twitter bot I
have suspicions over one or two I see
but cannot prove it at Twitter support
well I'm from Missouri which is a Show
Me State we're all skeptics and I would
always recommend that we'd be skeptical
of everything that we see if you have
suspicions go through a reporting flow
but you don't necessarily have to assume
that everyone is a but some people just
haven't updated their profile picture
and some folks haven't chosen their own
ad name so if you see some
thing that is suspicious we have a
reporting flow you can send it over to
us and we'll look for it I always be
skeptical at Peter I'll stone asks when
will Twitter Facebook and Google be
regulated like the public utilities they
are the information economy moves fast
maybe soon we believe fundamentally that
the job of regulator is to protect the
individual and level the playing field
for everyone and our job is to help
educate regulators around smart paths
forward so we're always having
conversations around the world with
regulators about what technology makes
possible and how Twitter fits into that
we welcome smart regulation and we want
to help guide it as well
at tazeed horas s IO Twitter can we get
that edit button in 2020 the answer is
no the reason there's no edit button
there hasn't been at a button
traditionally as we started as a SMS
text messaging service so as you all
know when you send a text you can't
really take it back we wanted to
preserve that vibe and that feeling in
the early days but now you know we have
an app and a lot of people are using us
on the web and there's some issues with
edit that we can we can solve one is you
might send a tweet and then someone
might retweet that and then an hour
later you completely change the contents
of that tweet and that person that
retweeted the original tweet is now
retweeting and Bri broadcasting
something completely different so that's
something to watch out for a lot of
people want it because they want to fix
a quick spelling error or a broken link
or whatnot
and that's great we've considered a one
minute window or a 30-second window to
correct something but that also means
that we have to delay sending that tweet
out because once it's out people see it
so these are all the considerations it's
just work but we'll probably never do it
okay at southern Peaks instead of an
edit feature Twitter should allow our
users to see how many times a tweet link
has been copied because we all send
tweets with did you see this one message
you know just to liven things up smiley
face I agree that's a that's a pretty
good idea
we'll look at that one at Allen lamp a
author hey Twitter God can you please
activate spell check I can't believe
there are so many trending misspelled
hashtags especially from writers at
least Tran that properly spelled
hashtags first hashtag writing community
hashtag writing community spelled wrong
hashtag writing community once again
build on our algorithms would actually
notice if these three hashtags were
trending and grouped them together so we
don't do the spell check and we don't
edit your tweet but we will group them
appropriately in the right way so that
everyone can find your content even
though you may have misspelled it at
Andre 3xk at Twitter why don't you
follow your boss at check Twitter was
following me for a while and then we
decided to do something much much cooler
we put a bunch of people on billboards
and their tweets on Billboard's all over
New York and San Francisco and we follow
them now and now we can DM them as well
so I don't really mind okay so at Garry
weights ask question of photographers
artists illustrators and creative types
have you read the new terms for Twitter
does this mean Twitter can do what they
like with our content and if you look at
the first screenshot it says you retain
your rights to any content you submit
poster display on or throughout the
services what yours is yours you own
your content and your incorporated audio
photos and videos are considered part of
the content so what that means is you
own it you can take it down at any point
you want me to read all the Terms of
Service study thanks tears well at Peter
Kim Frank is this article satire among
other things it claims that jack
regularly meditates two hours each day
spends 52 minutes each day doing sauna
plus ice baths eats just five meals per
week some of its real I try to meditate
two hours every single day I definitely
do not do a sauna and ice baths every
day and I eat seven meals every week
just dinner at LogMeIn 92 how does one
acquire the illustrious check mark on
Twitter there's a guy named Kevin and he
handles all the verification which is
the blue check mark so if you either DM
him
or mention him you have a high
probability of getting a blue checkmark
so it's at K a y VZ verification he's
the verification God so just go to him
and he'll get you sorted okay I have a
question from adapt to reality question
why is Jack going to Africa I am going
to Africa because it's a pretty
incredible collection of entrepreneurs
and folks that I think we all need to
learn from but I wanted to make sure
that I had a good understanding of
what's happening on the continent and
how folks are thinking about technology
and anything that we can do to help
support at vampire spelled VA EMP why
Ari does Twitter sell my data
immediately I like a few posts and I
immediately get ads about it no we don't
sell your data we try to match whatever
we think you might be interested with a
advertiser that is selling or offering a
service that matched those interest at
AI flops straits at Twitter when will
there be a dislike button we've never
actually thought of that so let's I'll
get that to the team and we'll get on at
bald subhan so apparently we can now
follow topics on Twitter but we can't
use or generate those topics wouldn't it
have been a thousand times easier better
to just let us follow hashtags well so
this is one step for us we're trying to
determine what the most interesting
topics are to start and this is all
based on our machine learning and deep
learning algorithms we bubble those up
so that you can follow them I recommend
following bird watching it's incredible
the other good one is weather but
there's over a thousand right now and
will get better and better so you should
see more and more topics but eventually
you might be able to follow a hashtag
but what's interesting about this
approach is that even if a hashtag is
not mentioned you'll still see a
relevant tweet above bird watching at GH
Mon berg asked at Jack what is your
favorite feature on Twitter well right
now it's the ability to follow topics I
think it's incredible it's awesome and
it works really really well
I'm finding so many accounts that I end
up following and so many tweets that I
would not have otherwise seen for sports
for weather and of course for
bird-watching at Robson ass at Twitter
can you just give us the ability to use
reg X unmuted tweets they never work
right so that's a very UNIX technical
term that's a regular expression
it's a pattern matching tool for a lot
of computer scientists we thought that
might be a little bit out of reach for
most people but it's a good suggestion
and our engineers back at the company
would love it so it probably can be done
tomorrow at underscore denial with two
A's in two ways
Twitter should have a close friend list
to write at Twitter who would you put on
your close friend list we'll look into
that but you can actually create a list
with all your close friends and put them
right at the top of your timeline and
switch quickly to them at any point so
we cannot really have that and Naini
Neal how does one trend on Twitter I've
been trying to figure that out for quite
some time who do you sell your soul to
not interested in trending but I'm
looking to get into the soul business
you know I think if you spread this
tweet around this one will probably
trend at the sorry paparella at Twitter
can we get translation option for any
tweet this already exists you can
translate any tweet that you see you
just tap into it and you hit translate
tweet at the Friars wife how do you
think or hope decentralizing Twitter
will transform the user experience well
the most amazing thing is I have no idea
and that's what makes it so exciting
we believe that Twitter is best served
by having the largest corpus of
conversations by having different
perspectives on how people consume those
conversations and interact with those
conversations I think generally it's
just going to create a ton more
invention for us and innovation for the
community using Twitter every single day
at koja Hiskey a tutor support is it
possible to claim an abandoned Twitter
handle that has zero followers only one
tweet and has been inactive since 2014
you can reach out to support directly
with the
out and we'll see what we can do thank
you this has been Twitter support I'm
Jack Dorsey and I would really love to
wish you all look great I ran out my
characters oh we have 280 I have a great
thing have an amazing day I hopefully I
was helpful if not mentioned me on
Twitter and I'll see what I can do